hello my name is Daniel Dwyer this is my
friend Andy bellman hey what's up we're
both individuals put together we form a
club drive hashtag club driving this is
dr club at PlayStation 4 exclusive
driving video game it's been at the
later bunch times but it's at this week
and we've we've got a little bit of a
early access preview for your folks here
we've got a bunch of restrictions on
this bad boy Ronnie bailout show some of
the sweet ass supercars I'm hypercars on
only for about 30 minutes so we're gonna
try to do that the hilarious part is
that we mostly have experience driving
cars that aren't these because we've
just done Lonnie's cuz you got to unlock
the super in cars so the other day the
other cars handle real good yeah they're
fun to race like the hot hatches yeah
you know the more performance stuff
whereas these ones go with twice as much
so that should be fun yeah driveclub so
let's let's hop right into it I show the
quick sort of demo of this menu stuff
just you know just be like that's like a
menu let's go to clubs I'll see it it
like cuz there's dried blood lines will
look at our club so the club stuff I
feel like we're not seeing the best off
at the moment because wearing gamespot
yeah please join the gang spa club
whenever you get into driveclub got four
places available and it's a it's level
two already look at us you got suite 300
k of experience driveclub points hash
points hash cloud points and yeah so the
the dot stuff is kind of hard to judge
right now because the game is not on yet
so yeah we need a wider breadth of
people yeah and the challenges in the
bottom left is kind of where your your
bodies or your clubs can like you issue
a challenge to like friends or other
clubs like drive this one in this
certain speed like i did this lap in a
minute forty try and beat it stuff like
that you can you can create great ones
too yes it's pretty cool um alright and
then drive is the top left which is
basically where most of the video game
is we go in there do it boom now we
wanted to show you that you can't really
change anything to settings like
assistance stuff but yeah yeah you kinda
manual to automatic in terms of the
gearbox and you but you can't change
anything abs or
or brake assistance or yeah we're
steering assistance around like that so
single fans and multiplayer are pretty
much you know as is there are
self-explanatory tor tor hop into that
blow up boy this is the progression of
the game pretty much okay let's go back
to the start we can't really do any
worse cuz these are all the lower of
cars but yeah you start off with the you
know hot hatches you work your way up
get some cool like you know more
performance and sport car some some of
them are single races sim events racism
I claps like try to beat a Time Trial
that you just you can just do infinitely
like I love those tracks as you can just
zone out and just trying to be a time
which is awesome yes like well all the
ones in this are either like two or
three laps of the circuit or like start
an end point and you get to it and but
what we'll see when we get into it is
that it's not just the race itself but
they put all these like kind of mid-race
objectives yeah they're funny challenges
I have really enjoyed playing those so
here is an actual series that we've
unlocked by getting 60 we had to get 66
stars we have to get because basically
what happens is see these are behind
these locks so yeah after 82 stars this
is going to become available but this
beats it's like super linear because
yeah like you don't pick the cars you
unlock you don't pick the races you
unlock it's like just race and do it
yeah and every railways kind of like
restricted to certain cars you can use
so this one don't do a full series
because it'll probably take too long oh
just do like a single event race so we
can mix it up well this is the only one
we can use oh no back up this is really
the only one we can use what about that
top one all right now II use the Bentley
of oh really so Ronnie alleges the so
due to the restrictions we can only show
you supercars all right do it we can use
the r8 this is on our approved list of
cars were legends paint jobs thank you
for any of these paint jobs let me prove
list oh whatever is that approved that's
approved okay eight gives you the logo
of your crew of obviously because it's
gamespot we've gone with the dead animal
skull we like our tex-mex right Chevy's
Shetty's day alright official birthday
dinner this handy this happens I've
that's coming up again I'm gonna go jevi
soon be healthy they make do this like
thing every time yeah getting into the
car
feeling the car and this game has a has
a [ __ ] with you for all of the hours oh
yeah and it's pretty detailed yes in
fact you could say his almost into
detail because the area of where your AC
is this small but it's they've got a
really good am sort of secondary look at
these scenics let's start the race where
are we don't know where we are alright
so I'm not this is literally undies
first time racing one of these supercars
I had to go earlier on may God have
mercy on your soul hell you're gonna
thank you for 40 I was yeah this is this
is tame but although I racing an r8 in
Forza is not a fun experience I don't
think because even though it's Quattro I
believe it's contro our big big right
here they just don't stay on the road so
that's one of those objectives you've to
stay on that blue line and it'll
basically like it's like a mini
objective during the race and it lets
give you a point score between you and
your buddies so you want it you better
bet all right video game person who we
don't know ok this is dead yeah after
spending so much playing this game in
the hot hatches another soul is raining
so fast it's no it's terrifying well
that too because the other thing is this
game has no replays this is not a no
rewind no no none of us can you hit
start actually for a second when you're
on a straight line is it no replay like
just general replay oh yeah photo stuff
oh no I guess not weird at the fit I
feel like the so Kevin Van Wert is doing
the official gamespot review and we've
played a bunch of it over the weekend
and last week I think we're kind of on
the same page oh yeah this is like a
it's a the driving a solid yeah but it's
it's it's not blacks I guess it's kind
of yeah there's not much happening in it
like a the club stuff we haven't really
seen properly ash and the AI is like
serviceable for you there they're really
stuck on their driving line though yeah
like they all kind of stick to that race
line they're really fun to overtake but
they don't come across as like very
human-like saying you know drive a
Tarzan forward to wherever the track the
tracks are pretty awesome though yes
variety and
environments and just the turnage like
and they're very forgiving like you can
kind of just bounce around the track
yeah I'd like you couldn't really stuff
like that it's like there's no you know
like that okay oh yeah I feel like this
is a kind of an entry like a layman's
driving game because there's none of the
you can't mess with the car as much you
know you can really like the tracks
aren't that difficult but then I found
like doing well on one corner and
getting enough speed for the next one I
take was really exciting so like you
know like the weight transfer when you
break is very very there like you feel
it which is important to kind of
learning how racing work so yeah so it's
weird it's like I feel like some this is
going to appeal I mean if you have a
Playstation that's all you have for this
anyone and driving game driving like I'm
I am I prefer the more simulation kind
of stuff i'll meet you a lot of the time
but I kind of still enjoyed this for
what it is like this this kind of
reminded me of the like call of duty of
driving games are so favored you know
it's like I pick up and play and you
know unlock some stars and I can see
myself actually going for the stars
that's pretty cool oh just getting like
both in the shade that wall I'll see you
later no replays back in the 10th uh I
could see myself going for the star
chase like over and over and over and
just getting really into it yeah try to
perfect the lab so perfect the time I
kind of feel like it's important to
people like maybe I'm perhaps I'm wrong
I got the impression for a lot of the
time with this that they were going for
something i kin to Kiki kind of maybe
not as heavy like towards the Forza like
scale of it where it's a little bit not
as totally crazy as that right but very
you know you know realistic and fun
driving I'm kind of in a way I'm kind of
happy this isn't just a lot of those
games like this very much it needs to be
different i got yeah but i also think a
lot of people are going to go into this
expecting one of those games and it's
not one of those eyes definitely an
expectation nation oh that didn't turn
out well but at least we finished wanna
do that one female protagonist every
race I've ever done in this game it's
how to grow bond
he's pretty key yeah I want the whole
price set that up because there's
definitely a screenshot it's like a bro
dude behind them no really uh continue
oh yeah we've got your clowns in design
right go baby so this one you're not
getting stars on that right finishing
top three and achieve a speed of at
least 15 5 so just at any point yeah
okay that's terrifying in in Forza I
feel like just well I play with like
everything office does often it's just
so fun that way because you even if you
get in the last I don't say like four or
five spots or you're in the middle or
you're in the top you're just finishing
a race and I and that mode is like you
you exhale you're like oh yes and I did
it and in this game I can see the
challenge being actually doing well yeah
you're chasing the stars are chasing the
times you're taking these mini
challenges where you you know you drift
or you get the bracing line or you get
the top speed yeah there's a lot of
repetition with those challenges it i
really like them but it's like oh yeah
there's the drifting one there's like an
average speed gate one there's a driving
line one and i think that might just be
it but they're really fun like they're
they put them in the clever parts of the
track and it kind of teach you like
they're kind of there to teach you yo
you should probably be going flat out
here you know you should probably take
this line yeah but like you're totally
right about the AI like all these guys
are basically in the perception is stuck
you know I and you can do that whole
thing where you just use them as
barriers to you know Amy might as well
because like there's no penalty really
yeah it's not the hardest game in a row
but then again the online stuff hasn't
been in yet and I have a feeling that a
lot of this game is going to be involved
you like trying to beat other human
players and people just can get super
good at drifting and yeah it's will be
impossible to win you get collision
penalties as well and if you hit people
too hard you can't accelerate yeah
that's bad form to second it gives a if
you go off the track it'll say you're
going to reset you in a couple of sec
yeah you can get a corner penalty if you
if you short the corner alright here's
here's a speed trap I've a feeling that
this might be the place i'm supposed to
get the ice oh [ __ ] no it's not oh so
it's cool it's cool the map is in the
bottom left and I it's so far away from
where I'm looking
that I tend to not use it very often all
right guys where everyone would've been
the best we were so good on this hot
hatches and stuff it's these okay yeah
you just gonna use to it it's gangster
all right I'll try and do it so what I
feel like you're chasing more gamey you
know which is cool you're chasing the
game objectives in this like you know
score stars points whatever Yara's
imports it's like kind of a channel ones
yeah it's like transcending yeah but
where you're just you're actually like
but there's not there's the nothing
wrong like I'm not saying that's better
or worse this is yeah this is just a
sort of a different game right now some
of the stuff like it kind of looks like
fine I didn't like them it doesn't look
incredible but they're even parts
there's one track where it starts in
like dusk and goes until nighttime over
the course of three laps and it was
fantastic I thought about it so much
such a great looking like a gorgeous it
was like it totally changed it to the
point where on the last lap it felt like
a different track I was like am I on the
same track is now that it's list it's
like this looks totally different well
you know the problem is I'm trying to
book it real hard so I can get there
catch up with these jokers this is not a
lot of road left I've sixty-seven
percent of them and they all they all
kind of they don't get too far out ahead
I don't know I feel like there's a
concertina effect happens like we're
because they're in all in a line they
kind of oh is that a real fast corner
sugar I should've taken faster that
party yeah like one of slows down see
look I'm like it's actually now you're
back to the time behind all I could get
into first right like I'm just a few
dress you'll be good like this is kind
of dumb then I was able to do this it's
so dumb but I kind of don't care cuz
this is the type of game that says I'll
come on eighty-five percent come on yeah
is there something you said for not
being completely punished for ruining a
turn all right I'm gonna concentrate
here try and get past these jokers
eighty-eight percent come on come on
come on come on you got tougher ones up
great turn and you'll or I just crash
into risk/reward baby oh damn it
that's sick overtake oh you didn't come
last baby dan I feel like such a jerk
you said you such a good member of the
club dragon see that's a good sign of
racing games and I would happily hit
restart on that and go for it go for it
again yeah so it's fun it's a one star
it's kind of super bare-bones like yeah
this is pretty much it that's not it
well again we don't know yeah the club
stuff if it takes off like that was the
thing like Burnett paradise whenever you
talk about burnout paradise I'm like
these are very different I'm not sure if
these I'm not sure they're on our probe
license but that's cool that you
actually unlocking and like obviously
they're totally two different games but
like how much of the like single-player
stuff to remember now like I just
remember that entirely as a trying to
beat everyone else's stuff so who knows
maybe that's a way better Hawaii looking
for haneda we're gonna do a hypercar now
are we really okay if you thought that
one was hard to control to maplewood i
don't know if that's a real city we got
a bunch of i'm pretty sure it's on
pretty sure Maplewood alright here's our
hypercar Maplewood Canada sounds legit
that's like that's like dream shillelagh
Ireland maybe like leprechaun Ireland
coconut Island California wiped up no
all right to make a name after Island
California are we able to use the rufc
RT oh yeah supersport we are so you want
to go hype do it that's good hope all
right all right apologies in advance to
everyone for like I believe in you in
your driving ability but the last time I
tried to do this it was ridiculously
fast which is cool because i made it
meant tackling that track totally
different yeah and it means getting a
handle on it so run semi-pro difficulty
I wonder if you can like to set that
stuff up you haven't done any yeah and
it's super hard maybe that automatically
takes your ass it'll assists away like
you can't granule II do I let's hop in
after after this bubbly yeah so let's
test it out to test out we're doing
games journals right live this is not
what that is no it's not what that is
right I don't know how fast is that
thing yes no like oh the yeah they're
like launch yeah yeah like the torque on
these things is insane let's go Oh No
okay that's so hard to drive no I'm not
do it do it do it it's for that it's not
for you it's for the stream I know but
true she's for the folks at home they
want to see the in-car view they were
probably screaming that whole other time
I was doing that lab Oh rice rice rice
oh yeah yes dumb because we cannot have
pulled the ebrake a lot of these tracks
of like environmental stuff like fog
rolls in there's a day-night stuff I see
some brain at the asian that forms on
the hood oh really know if it was
raining I was could have been to convey
it to go first I'll see I shouldn't have
ebrake again I didn't learn my lesson
you didn't you break did you I capped it
just so I could oh I didn't use either
haven't used in emergency braking once I
really I'm drift no oh yeah for drifting
maybe but i like the torgin this is
gonna be so crazy that i won't even risk
it like yeah it's too much so there's no
driving line objective a wheels are
butter which you actually did beat that
guy how's that hot i know i just have to
hear on it for two seconds careful oh oh
pro driving right there no excuse the
track to give me that on the phone take
that real shot on tango there you go you
gotta be 930 nailed it 978 nice work Ben
10 wow that's where my flags that only
those are red they were there oh don't
you conceited yeah all right all right
it sounds so much nicer right here as
well then I hear that wind and that
engine I said this is the term with the
you totally blew it on blu it in or the
ebrake so hey you go perfect hit-the
hit-the thought yeah there you go you
got a shutout
yes rom yeah you can just Ram it around
like speeds these guys pretty good and
then use them to like correct for your
turn which is really horrible because
these cars i wouldnt credibly expensive
like this laughs probably cost like 100
grand and this also be the lowest of the
hypercars cuz they're just they're
flying posture yeah there's accelerated
I think they got better left off that
last corner All Right see just flat out
here flat out that out yeah right yeah
its father oh and then you need to break
nice and early with this one yet oh
excuse the corner as my you got minus
250 I some 9,000 I believe in you is the
last lap they got half a lap left I
believe in you you can make it into the
single figures your intent at the moment
cool that's it yep nope Oh slowing you
down taking me I kind of like that
putting my governor that's a clever
mechanic I've never seen on the driving
game for him you got it you out of snail
oh that torque oh no I it's all gone
lasted I blasted the accelerator and it
is she's got blasted her asset remarried
tires this is it go go go go hahaha
blast it again it takes the back grade I
don't you well we're getting the hang of
it we're getting better at it yeah all
right I'm gonna tour it one more will be
top five absolutely we still got another
over the wall with this we got night we
were ten minutes oz will keep it at that
yeah keep it at the hypercar cuz that's
him sony wants to show you okay time to
see about these uh-oh choices you're
gonna try no I want to see the M the
difficulty stuff oh yeah I haven't done
much in Chile yet or not I change
difficulty
lake looks cool oh yeah I think that's
the one that turned from day to night
then setting there where is it oh you up
here hey guys oh it just changes the
opponent so number of opponents we can
go on pro I'm gonna stick it on pro and
see what happens time of day oh you can
do oh I wonder if we could have done the
M all right maybe do it on anything well
time any time compression you can turn
up really high oh yeah I'm down like 60
just 69 do any time a project clock
cycle yeah what time you think sundown
is in like in Chile northern Chile crowd
size large depends how far south they
are sundown could be really that's Fitz
winter or summer could never go down at
all all right four laps let's see how
unprofessional I meant you to see how
the cars handle if if it's the car
handling this difference on pro or if
it's the opponent opponents yeah it's
probably the opponent on semi-pro they
just kind of like these align right up
yeah like a snake yeah it's like not you
neither coming they got the AI from
Nokia all right weather cloudy don't be
cloudy I wanted to be damn it one of the
things Microsoft sold off what to sound
good day yes naked hey I keep snake all
right hopefully look at that sweet a
day/night cycle because I was real cool
when I did I think time compression x 60
it's just gonna constantly be on the Sun
is she's gonna be like whoo son okay
this is terrifying this is so fast oh
yeah your uphill kids crazy yeah and
these cars are definitely better already
yep it's going on guys
o'dwyer coming up behind you oh yeah
it's already sunset oh this is so fast
wow you have to be a reaction time wolf
Superman to get them I know your lights
are on yeah so it's it's time for
brushing why wonderfully I want to look
it by the time I finish this race it
might be to be more days we'll have like
three nights I go look at look at it
already okay cool this is yeah I love
this red yeah indication they like tell
you this is where the road is because
don't fly over the mountains okay I said
the professional they all seem to still
be in a man like a line is the only
worrying thing they're just cheating
thank you I'll look at the speed here
this is the one
yeah the penalty for it and the stuff is
pretty Oh as far as like speed dan Thea
it doesn't and there's no damage
modeling no there's no really there's
not even how much cosmetic damage either
but it's like scratches but I broke on
my side windows oh really wing mirror
all right how far my often two seconds
yeah come on I caught up with them a
little bit on that one I was a great
turn thank you I can't do the ebrake on
that when I haven't figured it out yet
it's with this car if it's hard because
bull Shh slam back on the accelerator
you're just spinning god I hope that
sunrise happens Oh Shh so god this car
is just made of evil your raw Ryder I
think it's DMX's favorite car a rough so
when I did this all my windshields
busted up a bit there and when I did
this on em in the hot hatches it was
awesome but this is a bit of a skilled
your speed jump maybe a bit too far for
me what's your which is he break is it a
circle you can change it to anything you
want though can you yeah none of the
many teachers right you can also play
inside other players according to the
back of the box which is yes you can
great feature if you think about I
disgusting well here we go i'm gonna go
start out here yep
also that's exciting Oh
ah
oh yeah yeah join our crew so what's
weird it's like a club it's like a house
my cosmetic damage like i enjoy this but
it's not the big fancy same thing that I
mean maybe maybe my expectations were
off something when so I'm do another one
you're one more yellow one all right
what are what are the non supercar one
can we do to Norway we can do a supercar
instead of a hypercar okay let's make
sure it's on the one on the list on our
way and do the time compression like
weed you want to do it do this Jordan
this one Lordan yeah hurdy gurdy good
okay I'm gonna sit these bad boys back
down to fix these semi-pro let's do this
back to 55 60 weather out here overcast
army store me or me if you have a
c-store me I need before that that might
bring us over in the time but we'll see
what happens oh I don't make okay hey
you play all right super car maybe yeah
go back do it whoa we can do ferrari ye
the fort or 30s good door I saw it on
there yeah yeah let's do it let's just
do factory cuz we're mess with candy red
oh yeah yeah well I'm fairness we're
gonna get a Ferrari and do a paint job
on of your history's greatest monster so
all right I believe in you plus I love
the yellow RPM leader Ferraris go sit
well with the red I've got five minutes
left of stream I paid two hundred
thousand dollars for that would you I
probably want it unhealthy or so I could
have a family in it would you pay two
hundred thousand dollars for drug club
well do you want to trade West you won't
have to because there's a demo of this
bad boy hitting a PSN is right yeah I
kind of well I demo I feel like it's
kind of a like a lot to keep making gran
turismo comparisons but am like a GT
prologue kind of situation maybe not
that fully featured but oh look is that
it Oh Ariel Atom in front of you yeah
wow we haven't unlocked out yet it's
level 28 oh this car drives nice yeah
compared to a rougher
no careful of the dude in the open-wheel
race I don't really seems like he's at a
quite a dangerous yeah event Oh purple
as well interesting Oh God oh look at
this oh this is stormy enemies in a
story would whoa oh is that not part of
it was racing a stormy Wow maybe gets
stormy sorry sorry no no no keep going
keep on but right semi-pro you're fine I
don't know there's no I had a 5.0 no
reason there now we've under God we
finna got like our 30-minute limit I'm
30 meter limit we've got like three
minutes left well three minutes 20
seconds we better go into hyper mode
definitely don't do that angle oh you
two got so slow not in manual I'm a
terrible backseat driver going the wall
oh look at this dude he in turn the one
I like yeah no one again yeah yeah you
gotta HD or HD all right there thanks
Gabe but it reminds me of the Lost Coast
oh oh yeah Horace Hey look I'm back of
the pack it would never happen in any
other racing game no like yeah it's
I feel like what I'm playing this game
I'm playing mario cars I feel like I'm
got a blur situation my god yes maybe I
really liked blur no but like just in
terms of the like like they're pretty
forgiving about getting you back in the
race and like you're always trying to
win like in Mario Kart you never trying
to come sixth what the hell the cars
gonna fire what would look like look
like again no no it's part of the track
I think okay fire pit oh I thought I'm
not crashing around a fire well you guys
watching oh yeah this fire pit there
haha of the car was on fire well they
just everybody just ganged up on oh this
is happening because you're using the
world's worst camera come on the car
that's my time neku if I can I'm gonna
play this side
what in the car right you can do it you
want no it's not that when I love that
view that's my favorite view but do the
next one hard to switch cuz the folks at
home want to see the Sun bumper and Mike
can't press bumper and trigger at the
same time looks pretty I'm not sure
about the storm remember to storm
happened I haven't seen rain at all
maybe this is none oh you're gonna hit
that thing again whoa whoa whoa the
storms coming in a patch probably I
don't not happy oh yeah have you got a
minute and 30 seconds well I better
start bridge real oh so good at night so
that's driveclub um yeah I hope this 30
minutes is kind of give you guys a taste
into what this game is it is not a big
simulation game it's kind of restrictive
there's not a lot like of depth in it
and it's it's kind of just a level up
unlock new cars unlock new events race I
guess the one thing we haven't seen is
if that Club stuff partha Mike you yeah
but we're down drew I guess we'll find
out like the challenge stuff it's just
not many people playing at the moment
alright let's back out to the menu
alright got tik-tok before we're led to
uh we're led to finish this bad boy yeah
yeah so at the full review will be
available on gamespot com later in the
week and his all mushy I'll go drive
club that was 80 seconds the logo
interpretation fair no green yeah the
review i'll be up later in the week um
yeah I think we're kind of on the same
page with this yes it's if you it's got
paid for real yeah if your ps4 anyone
driving game is probably want to get
something deepers experience in the
world but if nothing else the driving is
not realistic but fun pretty fun and
it's well it gives you a hint of
realistic like because you do want to
get the curves crack right 15 seconds
yeah you do want to race are more
footage for more coverage and all that
madness of growth Club go to gamespot
com thanks for watching